grande mobilisation citoyenne
aujourd'hui dans toute la france pour
dire non à l'extrême droite
un galop d'essai avant la manifestation
du 1er mai dans la capitale 45000
personnes selon la police
cent mille selon les organisateurs ont
marché entre république et nation à
l'appel de 80 associations syndicats et
partis politiques
un rassemblement qui s'est passé plutôt
dans la bonne humeur reportage de l'ucla
gars boucher et christofi l'art et de la
musique et des sourires voilà pour le
ton de la riposte
le message lui on ne peut plus clair les
milliers de citoyens descendent tous
dans la rue pour les mêmes raisons
on est tous pareils on est tous il n'est
pas la même chose on peut pas de l'open
ben alors à turny en affirmant je
l'aimais rivière la jeunesse elle
sauvera peut-être six mois je voit
réapparaître cette trappe et le spectre
de l'ail et le spectre de l'horreur mais
vous savez pour moi le pen tirait il ya
les habitués des manifestations qui
défilent sous leur bannière et des
bannières il y en a 60 60 associations
syndicats et partis politiques qui
appellent à ce rassemblement il ya les
gens connus responsables ou artistes
comme ici jane birkin et charlotte
gainsbourg ou encore un peu plus loin
jacques higelin ce qui leur dit ce sont
des gens qui
politique et une morale qui est fait du
tout celle de tous les ans qu'ils sont
là
le tout une partie de la france qui
résiste à ce fascisme
quoi qu'ils disent c'est quand même des
gens d'extrême droite et je veux pas
personne ne veut que ces gens là est où
ton influence
et puis il ya les autres tous les autres
les sens non la majorité silencieuse
celle qui habituellement regard de
passer le défilé sans y prendre part
c'est exceptionnel mais je suis rarement
malik d'ailleurs donc pouvait obliger
voilà pourquoi des dérangements da vinci
pour lui mais en fait aujourd'hui un
joyeux melting potes avec en toile de
fond des images qui font peur un méli
mélo de couleur pour faire barrage à
jean marie le pen
un galop d'essai avant la manifestation
unitaire du 1er mai une répétition qui
jusqu'à présent se déroule sans incident